humans need dentists it's a fact in 2017
alone Americans spent 129 billion
dollars on dental visits an an estimated
90% of adults in the US have fillings
but many animals don't have this problem
because they can regrow their teeths
replacing old damaged ones with
brand-new pearly whites wouldn't it be
great if you could do that well there's
actually an important trade off for this
nuisance only a handful of mammals can
regrow teeth multiple times compared to
the 50,000 species of reptiles and fish
to get goes for example they replace all
100 or so teeth every three to four
months and since geckos can live for six
to ten years they'll grow anywhere from
1,800 to 4,000 teeth in a lifetime
that's all thanks to a special type of
cell in their gums
called stem cells stem cells are handy
because they can morph into different
cells when needed like teeth stem cells
to build new teeth humans have these
stem cells when we're younger but after
our adult teeth grow in the stem cells
die and disappear to understand why
let's take a journey back in time to
about 320 million years ago when mammals
and reptiles split off in addition to
many obvious differences another change
that eventually emerged was tooth shape
reptiles for example are what's called
generalists meaning they eat the animals
they can get their teeth on and for that
they needed teeth with the same size and
shape to keep prey from escaping their
mouths mammals on the other hand
developed more specific diets like
grazers who only eat grass and hunters
who rip flesh from their kills
as a result mammals evolved different
shaped teeth for different purposes and
it's this difference that could also
explain why mammals can't regrow more
teeth now let's say you could regrow
your molars molt
times for example it's important that
the top and bottom sets match up
otherwise they can't grind food as
efficiently that sounds good in
principle but with each new set there's
a risks that the regrown teeth won't
line up so the leading theory is that
adult humans can't regrow our teeth
because it was better for survival to
only grow one well-aligned
adult set however if you still wish you
could regrow a tooth there may be a way
in the future using lasers and drugs
scientists have helped rats and mice
regrow damaged tissue in cavity written
teeth with the idea that if you could
regrow tooth tissue you could eventually
regrow entire teeth though
no human testing has been done on that
yet so keep flossing and keep seeing
your dentist at least for now
[Music]